the New York Times coverage of President
Trump is the subject of a new
documentary series in the Fourth Estate
viewers get an unprecedented
behind-the-scenes look at times
journalists investigating and reporting
the biggest headlines of the
administration's first year this preview
features Washington bureau chief
Elizabeth view Miller editing with a DC
based correspondent as they face a
changing news a changing news cycle and
a tight deadline I'm not talking to them
and that's not gonna matter I'm not you
pick it up pick it out hello it's Mike
here I'm the secretary here we're doing
your lead we're doing the lead and we're
just kind of submitting it out and do
you want to talk to him no a call from
New York with suggestions for Washington
familiar to anybody Hugh Miller joins us
now along with the executive director
Dean Beck a who is also featured in the
series the Fourth Estate will air on
Showtime a division of CBS welcome to
both of you New York and Washington that
great tension at the heart of any
journalistic enterprise
Dean Beck hey why did you let cameras
into the New York Times because I
thought that if people got a glimpse
inside a newsroom a modern newsroom they
would they would understand there were
human beings that we have a mission that
we make mistakes but that we work
extremely hard they were not biased I
just thought that that the days when we
would not allow people to see that
process to be over
and I thought it would help us I want to
get to that idea of human beings in a
second but as you both know any good
story starts with a strong lead this
series opens up on inauguration day that
it's it's a cloudy day but it opens up
with clouds over the White House and the
editor staring at the screen as if
they're watching a funeral won't people
watching this think this confirms every
feeling I have about the New York time
being biased about this president except
right after that scene as I recall and
it was it was unrehearsed I sort of
break into a grin and just acknowledge
our biggest story it is
I don't think so I mean I really don't
think so first up it was a grim
inaugural speech it was meant to be grim
it's hard not to have had a grim
reaction texts of this yeah that's right
I mean this this was the American
carnage speech but I also think people
saw a newsroom suddenly sort of turn up
the volume and get ready to cover it and
see the joy and in reporting and say
we're gonna get it right the thing that
struck me develop on what you said Dean
is you show us a how hard people work
and at one point I think it was Mazzetti
who said you know we want to be first
but more importantly we want to be right
and there were times that a story was
delayed while you all were working so
hard to make sure that you get it right
right right and there was I think that
was one of them Michael one of them
Michael Flynn's stories and we delayed
and the post beat us on that story and
we I think we came back really strongly
the rest of the year and right after
that I see the tension that we have yes
and the competition there's just a lot
of stresses on us because if you listen
to President Trump it would seem that
the that the New York Times tries on a
daily basis just to take him down to try
to find things that are negative about
him to take it down when in fact you've
expanded the bureau to get it right
right the bureau's now most people on
Election Day 2016 it was 70 people so
you can see what we've done we've added
there's six White House reporters now
there used to be four we've added an
investigations team we've added a lot
more editors more visual journalists
it's a it's a we're out of desk in the
bureau basically there's a scene where
Jim Ruttenberg who is your media
reporter gets off an elevator and he has
paint on his shoulder I thought when I
first thought that it was ripped or
something I thought gosh he really is
working hard but in the paint because
the New York Times is under construction
and he says the New York Times is losing
money to Facebook and Google not because
we're dying for readers we've never had
more but those platforms they've eaten
away at our business Dean how has it
challenged the print business sure he
was making a larger economic point which
in fact the platform's have have gained
so much advertising at the expense of
institutions like the New York Times
though I will add the New York Times is
doing financially quite quite well I
mean we have a a tense
relationship with the platform's we do I
mean okay yeah on the one hand we have
to be where the readers are I mean our
power comes from being read and they
have a lot of our readers on the other
hand I think they're struggling with how
they manage us I think they're
struggling with how they define
journalism and I think they're reeling
particularly Facebook from from the
events of the last election Elizabeth
you've been a longtime watch reporter
we've worked together covered campaigns
and been in the White House and the
Pentagon together and now you're editing
for many who read and say where do these
sources come from and the term leaking
from the White House it always suggests
that someone has an agenda explain how
you get information from the White House
in the administration well there's a lot
of different ways as you know you cover
it you outside in strategy you cover the
hill you cover the agencies and then you
check with the White House the idea that
leaking is sort of this passive thing
that we just sit there and receive
information this is not true at all yeah
these reporters what I think one of the
things I've learned as an editor is to
watch so many different reporters work
so many sources in different ways
they're amazing and it's a lot of hard
work it's a lot of getting people to
trust you it's it's just it's digging
and putting stories together and we've
different White House's have treated
them all treated the press
antagonistically george w bush clinton
the obama administration was in stream
right agonistic this works as well this
one of course it's publicly entitled and
more antagonistic yes but how in terms
are forcing Elizabeth do you find your
reporters find it well it's it's hard
because you often hear the exact
opposite thing from very senior people
at the White House in the same hour
you've got to balance out what is true
and what is not it's it's just it's a
much bigger reporting challenge that
said I was saying we're not passive
recipients of leaks that the federal
bureaucracy is very leaky right now
because it's a it's a it's a bureaucracy
that's been there for a long time and
many of them are not happy with what
Trump is doing so we're finding that I
mean and also at the White House there's
a lot of different agendas and different
a different kind of you had different
people fighting with each other so that
creates a game roans a lot of
information right
think the worst words that you hear in
your documentary is where did the
Washington Post get that story the fact
that everybody's face is like how did
they get it we've been working on it -
yeah we don't competition is real very
real competition is one of the least
examined aspects of journalism and it's
it's healthy but the fact that we're in
a day to day battle with the Washington
Post in particular is good for them it's
good for us it's good for journalism
yeah I mean imagine if only one news
organization one print one paper was big
enough I do all this by itself it would
be isolated if you wanna be healthy well
it's a great series and you really take
we see the humanity that reporters and
their lives and how you do what you do
it's great really great executive editor
Dean Beck a and Washington bureau chief
Elizabeth few Miller thanks to both of
you in the first episode of the Fourth
Estate airs Sunday night on Showtime a
division of CBS